[Music]
hi
i'm alex cookson and i'd like to talk
about the power of great data sets
i'd like to start off this talk by
posing a question i think all of us have
asked ourselves at one point
and that is how do i learn to do this
thing
in r whether that's sentiment analysis
or data visualization or web scraping
how do we learn something and allison
horst
who does a lot of wonderful
illustrations about r and statistics has
one that
answers this question and it shows how
teachers mentors and the wonderful
rstats community
all contribute to taking someone from
being a beginner to some level of
proficiency with something
but i always look at this illustration
and
ask myself what about great data sets
now when i say great data sets i'm
talking about something pretty specific
i'm talking about data sets that are
both cool and interesting
and when i say cool i mean something
that when you come across it you say to
yourself hey that's cool or that's
really fun it's
something that speaks to you on a deeper
level and it tends to be pretty personal
so what's cool to you might not be cool
to me
and when i say interesting i mean that
it rouses your curiosity it makes you
start asking a whole bunch of questions
that you really want the answer to
if you've ever played a video game where
you say to yourself just five more
minutes
or one more turn and you're still
playing it an hour later
this is the data set version of that
just one more graph
so some examples that uh i enjoy
are the duke lemur center data set which
looks at
ages and weights of almost 30 different
species of lemur
the broadway grosses dataset which looks
at
weekly box office grosses tickets sold
average top ticket prices of broadway
shows going back to 1985
and fictional character personalities
which i consider to be one of the
all-time
greatest of great data sets and this one
looks at
personality traits of 800 fictional
characters across
over 250 different spectrums such as
the playful to sirius spectrum where we
might find michael scott from the office
on the playful side
and dwarf from star trek next generation
way over on the serious side
and i think this is such a great data
set because i've been watching so much
tv
and so many movies lately that when i
came across it i thought ah this is so
fun it's something that
speaks to something i've been spending a
lot of my time doing and i immediately
had tons and tons of questions that i
wanted to ask it
and uncover from this data set one of
those questions was
what are some of my favorite characters
personalities and i put in a whole bunch
of work and ended up with some graphs
that looked like this
which takes the six characters from
pride and prejudice
and shows their strongest traits so we
see that elizabeth bennett at the top
left
is a treasure as opposed to trash she's
important
she has a high iq she's independent and
beautiful and a feminist
but to put this together i had to learn
to do a whole bunch of things i didn't
know how to do before
like use custom fonts so i could get
this georgian era kind of handwriting
vibe
to tweak labels using the glue and gg
text packages
i had to choose an appropriate color
palette for the subject matter
and adjust a ton of theme elements using
ggplot2
a second question i had was which
characters are most similar to or
different than one another
and again i put in a bunch of work and
ended up with something like this which
looks at reasonable versus deranged
characters plotted against
rugged versus refined characters so here
we see that characters like sandra
clegane and jane cobb
are really similar to one another
they're deranged and rugged and their
opposites are charlotte york from sex
and the city and annie edison
who are reasonable and refined and to do
this
i had to conduct principal component
analysis with tidy models
because these are actually principal
components you don't find them in the
data
i had to learn to add text and arrow
annotations to get this graph here
and i wrote a blog post where this is an
interactive chart so
i had to learn how to make an
interactive chart using plotly
and if i can be honest with you for a
moment i
never would have put this much effort
this many hours
into analyzing titanic passengers it was
because it was such a great engaging
data set
where i had tons of questions that i
wanted the answers to that i had the
drive and the curiosity
to actually get those answers and learn
a whole bunch of stuff in the process
so i encourage you to get your own great
data sets and to allison
i very respectfully that we maybe add
one thing to the balloon
thank you
[Music]